going into uh christmas you got any
advice for folks in terms of how they
can help orange peel their family
that's a good question a twitter user in
the us can send a tweet that tweet can
be received by user in japan by a user
in africa by user in the middle east
what if though that user in japan wanted
to tip you pomp for this amazing show
and your amazing tweets and you had your
venmo account linked out of luck what
the internet did for communication is
before if you wanted to send a message
to someone in japan a long time ago you
would write it on a thinly sliced piece
of wood and you'd send a [ __ ] pigeon
to go fly it across and hope that they
delivered you know the
the pigeon spits your note out it's
whoever you want to read it you're like
hey what are you doing for dinner and a
pigeon spit is all over the message that
you tried to send now you can send a
tweet what the internet did to
communication is it gave the world a
singular global protocol now let's
revisit money today today money is still
in pigeon land
money is still in writing of course
carriage to deliver newspaper land where
if you're in the u.s you've got cash app
in venmo you know western union is for
remittance but if you go to starbucks do
you use western union no you use your
visa card but if you're online and you
buy some merchandise you use stripe
they're independent bifurcated closed
networks to accomplish monetary
settlement what bitcoin and the lighting
network does is it gives the world a
global singular protocol for monetary
settlement in the same way that the
internet is a global singular protocol
for communications okay and so now all
of a sudden pom if your venmo account is
linked to your twitter account can
someone from japan tip you a penny
no
but if you're hooked into the singular
global interoperable monetary protocol
for the world can they type your penny
over the lightning and bitcoin network
yes in order to have that you'd have to
have a money that works everywhere in
the world that lives outside of a
governance by a nation state that lives
outside of an issue in termination state
from a company so bitcoin as the only
digital bear instrument on the planet is
a precursor to this experience and then
on top of that you need a protocol that
can allow it to achieve instant physical
bear instrument settlement and free
physical bearing treatment settlement
and that's the lightning network and
combined what the internet did for
communication bitcoin and the lightning
network is doing for money i start by
saying the human condition is elevated
via the channeling of energy and every
great advance was a new form of energy
via metallic energy in the form of steel
or electrical energy or chemical energy
and uh and bitcoin is the next evolution
of that
right so the first reason is it's
compelling and critical to the events of
the human race the second observation is
every successful investment idea in the
21st century was a digital
transformation digital transformation of
music digital transformation of of uh
entertainment digital transformation of
books digital communications bitcoins
the digital transformation of everything
else everything that didn't get tr
didn't get transformed in the in the
first
in a chapter of the mobile wave comes
next so now we have digital
transformation of gold digital
transformation of property and digital
transformation of energy and for the
first time in the history of the human
race you can literally take energy
transform it into something in
cyberspace store it forever move to the
speed of light
program it and eliminate the friction
that that is applied to to that energy
when it takes another form
650 billion dollars has been printed by
the federal reserve this year that's
killing the people
in our family that didn't get educated
or don't own bitcoin you know i'm from a
family of immigrants as you know italian
immigrants they can't catch up with this
nonsense you and i can own assets our
assets are going to appreciate and our
standard of living will be just fine but
if you're a wage holder and the federal
reserve is printing 700 billion dollars
of money you're screwed pump and i and i
told you that when we first met when
they broke the contract with gold in
1971 they slowly eroded middle and lower
middle class living standards and now
we're living in an age of populism uh
economic desperation for a large group
of people which used to be economic
aspiration and we've weakened the
society so when you see something like
bitcoin you're like oh my god this is a
technological innovation which can
actually be a store of value for those
people can help the underbanked and
could literally transform the world i do
believe there will be a time when energy
oil and natural gas is priced in bitcoin
i think vlad putin is thinking of that
right now okay and to do that he's
basically think how does he get out of
the petrol dollar he doesn't want uh to
hold us treasuries in reserve those are
fiat contracts that are programmed to
debase what if he took bitcoin and
payment for his energy wow then he's
starting to build up a reserve of the
most pristine collateral ever
digital energy being paid for natural
resource energy i think it's inevitable
i'm an engineer like sailor i'm just
playing the odds and then if that
happens
five percent of 200 or of 900 trillion
quickly becomes 20
of 200 trillion and all of a sudden my
price target for bitcoin isn't 2 million
it's something like 20 million a coin
play the odds guys this is the racetrack
this is how you manage risk